there's recently been some pretty huge
leaks and rumors concerning apples 2019
iPhones so we thought we'd round them
all up so you guys could get a good idea
of what to expect in September let's get
started about a week ago renders of a
2019 iPhone 11 with the triple lens rear
camera were leaked by on leaks but the
implementation of the camera seemed far
from what would be designed by Apple the
report from digit I n didn't give any
reason for the triple-n's camera but
earlier reports showed that Apple was
interested in Sony's 3d camera
time-of-flight technology which is able
to map rooms in real time for augmented
reality and increased camera autofocus
performance that sounds exciting and it
totally seems like something Apple would
do but that rear camera design was awful
thankfully a couple of days ago compared
rajah released exclusively leaked
renders of a horizontally stacked triple
lens camera now this one looks more like
what Apple would actually release the
interesting thing we see here is that
the flash is actually built into a ring
around the center lens and I'm loving
this idea alternatively Ben Gascon
created renders of the triple lens rear
camera in the same position as the
current iPhone 10s and that may actually
make more sense just yesterday more info
was leaked about the new iPhone 11
compare Raja noted that two of the three
rear sensors are 10 and 14 megapixels
details of the third sensor are still
unknown the selfie camera was also noted
to pack a 10 megapixel sensor which I'm
really excited about since there's still
a lot of room to grow there
recent rumors from digit Times and John
Baptist Zoo claimed that the 2019 iPhone
11 would switch from a lightning port
two USB see but compared Raja seems to
disagree they noted that the 2019 iPhone
will still pack a lightning port but we
won't know for sure until September
either way we expect this year's iPhone
to come with a new 18 watt USB C charger
in the box
concerning face ID mingsha quo is
predicting that Apple will increase the
power output of the flood illuminator
which should make face ID more accurate
there's also a chance that we'll be
seeing the implementation of vane ID
which would allow face ID to scan the
veins inside a user's face making it
even more secure but we may not see that
until at least 2020
another thing we may not see this year
is the switch to 5g and I'm totally okay
with that 4G LTE already supports
download speeds much faster than what
even the iPhone 10 s is able to achieve
due to cellular provider limitations as
for the knotch Ben Gaskin believes the
infrared lens and front camera on 2019
iPhones will be integrated into each
other making the not smaller than it
currently is I for one wouldn't mind
this at all
but what about the complete removal of
the notch altogether now we most
definitely shouldn't expect this until
at least 2020 but there's possibly a way
for the true depth camera array to work
from beneath the display how well am s
an Austrian company recently launched an
optical sensor that works from
underneath an OLED display this type of
technology can be utilized by Apple to
implement the face ID sensors under the
display as for the camera itself it
could be hidden by using transparent
OLED technology which is already being
used by TV manufacturers the OLED pixels
above the camera lens would simply be
turned off whenever you open the camera
app or any other app that uses it and
when it's not in use you'll get a full
face display just don't expect this for
another couple of years
a report from Barclays analyst Blaine
Curtis said that the 2019 iPhones could
feature Wi-Fi 6 otherwise known as 802
11 8 X which will be anywhere from 4 to
10 times faster than the existing 802 11
AC to make it even better it should
increase overall battery life due to a
new feature called wake time scheduling
as for display technology Apple could be
using Samsung's y octa OLED panel
technology in the 2019 iPhones this
would integrate the touch layer directly
into the OLED display making it thinner
and cheaper to produce for this reason
we may see a complete switch to OLED on
all 2019 iPhone models and asked for
touch ID don't expect it to come back
anymore mingsha quotas face ID has
become too accurate and successful for
us to knee touch ID he also said that we
shouldn't expect better waterproofing
any time soon since ip68 is already more
than good enough for what most users
will need it for and there's one last
thing before we end this video air power
marketing material has been spotted on a
Malaysian site alongside the new iPhone
smart battery case
this shows that Apple has an abandoned
air power
we're likely to see a release sometime
in 2019 so there you have it there are
all the 2019 iPhone 11 leaks and rumors
comment below if I missed any and be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on more videos like this one